thank you very much on this Good Friday
Christians from all around the world
remember the suffering and death upon
the cross of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ and Easter Sunday we will
celebrate his glorious resurrection at
this holy time our nation is engaged in
a battle like never before the invisible
enemy
our brave doctors nurses and responders
first responders responders of all are
fighting to save lives our workers are
racing to deliver critical medical
supplies our best scientists are working
around the clock to develop life-saving
therapeutics and I think they're doing
really well in doing so our people are
making tremendous sacrifices to end this
pandemic though we will not be able to
gather together with one another as we
normally would on Easter we can use the
sacred time to focus on prayer
reflection and growing in our personal
relationship with God so important I ask
all Americans to pray that God will heal
our nation to bring comfort to those who
are grieving to give strength to the
doctors nurses and health care workers
to restore health to the sick and to
renew the hope and every person who is
suffering our nation will come through
like never before
I thank the many families who have
prayed for me and for my family and your
prayers are felt and I am forever
grateful I'd like to thank our great
vice president and his wonderful wife we
all know very well Karen for the
incredible job they do and for their
service not only to the country but for
their service to God almost 3,000 years
ago the prophet Isaiah wrote these words
darkness covers the earth but the Lord
rises upon you and his lorry appears
over you for the Lord will be your
everlasting light as our nation battles
the invisible enemy we reaffirm that
kids believe in the power of prayer we
give thanks for the majesty of creation
and for the gift of eternal life and we
place our trust in the hands of Almighty
God I'd like to just wish everybody a
very happy Easter we're going to be
celebrating that very very special day
and it's going to be hopefully a very
good weekend and a very productive
weekend and I want to thank everybody in
our country and beyond
for all they've had to put up with 184
countries as of this morning are
fighting this enemy and we pray for them
all with that I'd like to introduce
Bishop Harry Jackson from Maryland
highly respected gentleman who is a
member of our faith and a person that we
have tremendous respect for Bishop
please Thank You mr. president first of
all let me say thank you for the job you
doing you the vice president to protect
our nation and you've included the
churches and the relief efforts many
churches would have had to close down
had it not been for your insightful
leadership so thank you both very much
thank you I good Friday as we prepare to
praise is one of the darkest days in the
Christian faith in that Christ stood in
substitution for our sin but the
resurrection is our victory but it
parallels with the Passover I'm going to
read two verses and pray out of them
about what we want to have happen we
want this plane to pass over we want
everyone in America to be safe Psalm 105
says he brought them out without with
gold silver and gold and there was none
feeble among his tribes verse 39 goes on
to say he spread a cloud for covering
and fire to give
in the night let's pray Lord let the
Death Angel Passover let there be a
mitigation of this plague this disease
that medical science come forth Lord let
us come out with a thriving economy that
silver and gold spoken of in that
passage let it be our portion and then
God as we face other challenges in the
future
Lord covers with a cloud by day and a
fire by night but in this great land
that was set up to glorify your name we
want to break we come against the spirit
of division Lord let eat the porpoise
you be a reality in us that there be a
uniting of America heal the divide
between race class and gender once again
give this great man our president and
give the vice president wisdom beyond
their natural limitations give them
insight so they can cover us lead us and
bless us we bless them and America in
Jesus name be encouraged hope is on the
way amen thank you this beautiful thank
you but I was a great honor thank you
and thank you all and have a great good
Friday and we're gonna see you in a
little while and also if I don't see you
have a great Easter thank you very much
Thank You mr. president mr. president
what's your message to churches should
pastors have Easter services
we ask you then at the briefing okay
thanks Happy Easter
Thanks